Christmas just five days away now and
though inflation has showed some signs
of easing many Americans are still
feeling it seven percent inflation is
not nothing according to a recent Gallup
survey most Americans 55 percent say
they have experienced financial hardship
because of rising prices but inflation
does not have to be the Grinch that
steals Christmas Nancy Chan is here with
some ways to save money is it possible
Nancy good morning it's a good question
good morning to you Tony it can be the
most wonderful time of year but also the
most stressful especially when it comes
to money but there are ways to manage
this gift-giving season without taking
on debt
what do you want to eat then buddy for
Francesca DeVito feeding her four kids
is where inflation has hit the hardest
we do a lot more frozen veggies same
with fruits try to stretch as much as I
can stretching has also been debt even
after downsizing into this mobile home
in New Jersey it seems like these credit
cards are a matter of necessity for you
yeah it's what gets you in between
paycheck and then unfortunately your
paycheck goes to trying to pay it down
and then it comes down to am I going to
pay the credit card down am I going to
pay the light bill now with holiday
bills looming DeVito and her husband are
focusing on cutting back further to
afford Christmas for their children but
it hasn't been easy here's the chip or
do you slide even as inflation cools
costs are still up more than seven
percent from last year on average
Shoppers are expected to spend about 833
dollars on holiday items including gifts
the holiday season can be really
overwhelming but you can save money I
like to call it post-traumatic broke
syndrome Tiffany liche is a financial
educator featured in the Netflix
documentary get smart with money our
first tip to save you make a list you
check it twice and see who's going to
get a gift or not so not everyone's
going to get again oh a recent survey
found that 26 percent of consumers plan
on shortening their gift list this year
with just close family making the cut as
budgets are stretching credit card our
debt has soared 15 percent in the last
year a pace not seen in more than two
decades reaching a record 930 billion
dollars as the average interest rate
nears 20 percent lyche says instead use
debit cards or cash unless you're
someone who pays off their credit card
debt every single month in full if you
are that person then using a credit card
that generates points so it allows you
to travel allows you to earn cash back
or gas then you're okay and although by
now pay later options are increasingly
popular Alicia recommends steering clear
of them when it comes to gifts the worst
thing you can do with your finances is
to be paying monthly on things that
ideally you should be saving up for and
paying off in full when you get that
thing
another tip consider group gifts or
doing a secret santa especially if you
have a large family that way you don't
need to buy a presents for every single
person it is so hard to save especially
this time of year if you are last minute
shopping but every dollar does count big
fan of the group gift just sign the card
put a bunch of names on there it's from
all of us you don't even have to talk
but Tiffany had really good advice I'm
wondering what her friends and family
are thinking when she's made it clear
ain't everybody on the list getting a
gift this year but I think a lot of
people are in that yes the thought that
counts I really care about you I was
thinking about you this Christmas
take it with you at the gift level but
at the thought about level yeah that's
great it goes a long way yeah thank you
Nancy thank you